[Music]
opening up a show about ducks with
anything other than a duck is a quacking
sin
this is clearly a goal ass and not a
duck tale also show chooses not to open
with the greatest tv theme song of all
time it's a fact
don't bother checking i'm always curious
about animal sentience in shows like
this
some animals wear clothing and talk
while others fly around like normal what
makes these ducks different than the
seagulls
you can't wear this to your job
interview why is donald covering his
lower half and not his upper when
clearly exposure below the shirt hemline
is
no ducking deal also why don't ducks
wear pants in the world of disney that's
even more of a mystery than whether or
not walt disney is under cinderella's
castle on ice
also also he totally is either these
clothes are so stiff they can be
suspended like this without a hanger or
this is a tee that looks like a jacket
shirt and tie but is actually a prank
gift from a novelty store
both are a sin um is donald's shirt
sentient because
now i have even more questions the big
day calls for a big
breakfast fish for breakfast also never
trust anyone who can perfectly craft
letters around the rim of a plate
whether ketchup jam or blood this is a
food trim that makes all of us look bad
oh come on how hard is it to roll down
the plastic bag and close the cereal box
i don't know this house doesn't even
appear to have an
address and what cab or bus driver would
just leave an elderly woman all alone at
a clearly abandoned house in the middle
of nowhere did they just put the entire
suit on donald all at once because i'm
calling bull quack on those suit physics
i heard he's so smart he solved the
mystery of the chupacabra scrooge mcduck
is the chuck norris of ducktales
maybe that's not a sin but it's how i
show i care also can we discuss the last
name for a second i'm guessing duck is
just the smith of duck names although i
don't know too many people called donald
human but semantics
however why is scrooge a mcduck and
donald his nephew is just simply
duck i mean what the duck is up with
that he only hunts for treasure
to swim in it keeping swords in your
swimming pool
back in the bed with you see you
tomorrow old bored rich guy is old bored
and rich cliche
i don't know is it smart to have a
monolith beacon of a vault shouldn't
rich people hide their treasures instead
of giving every thief a massive target
what the [ __ ] is this guy doing he's
driving while standing out of a sunroof
while somehow keeping his hat on his
head this is ridiculous even by cartoon
standards
i know this is supposed to show launch
pad as an irresponsible driver but i
think it does the opposite he managed to
take out the table and dessert but not
the pigs and the dog that is one skilled
duck
a sword by a fireplace no big deal but
an umbrella
flinging embers could easily ruin the
fabric do you know how hard it is to
find the right [ __ ] umbrella store
that thing in a closet
hmm this is the third or fourth time
this headline has been obviously pointed
out
i wonder if it will be important you
agreed to watch them watch them
i'm gonna be honest i don't think that's
how this went down but i couldn't
understand most of what was being said
between donald and scrooge earlier so i
don't know exactly what the [ __ ] is
going on
i'm here for it but clueless i just want
to point out that webby has installed a
clapper for one specific spotlight in
her room for dramatic effect
the lisa's not the marble room yes but
you're following a child who attached a
doll to the wall by piercing it with an
arrow
so i don't really think we can trust
your judgment because
family is nothing but trouble
blue shirt kid duck can act shocked but
hdl are notoriously rambunctious and
love causing trouble so this shouldn't
come as any surprise the kid should be
nodding like he's got a point come on
writers find a better angle for your
family rift
i'm scrooge mcduck i made my name being
tougher than the toughies and smarter
than the smarties
smarties are the devil's work bitter
chalky choking hazard pseudo candy i
just can't tolerate them so i'm sending
this show for making me think of them
i'm gonna eat a hamburger which got me
thinking about how ducks eat so i looked
up that teeth and now i'll never sleep
again
shield your eyes children the gong of
pishu
hit it three times to unleash
unspeakable evil
for the last time hitting a bong does
not unleash evil there are incredible
medicinal
what's that oh gong gong right uh what
are you doing calling dibs on stuff
you at least have to write your name on
the post it's louie do you even know how
to dibs bro
that one feels self-explanatory webby
vanderquack would be ducktastic at tv
sins
secret museum this is the garage
see it's funny because it's a garage and
garages are funny because
it's a garage for garage things which is
why this is so
funny the curse is only activated if you
ring the gong three times and
and and you already hit it two times
didn't you there's no way the gong
hasn't been accidentally tapped a few
times before now
especially considering it's stored in
the garage where anyone could run into
it when they put away their hoses
of destiny it'll take more than some
fancy flying to shake old scrooge
cannibal and being able to defy the laws
of physics also we'll handle the witty
alliterations around here scrooge
show off launchpad we need to swing him
out behold the plane of forgetful
artistry three windows turn into two
so what's the big deal if the dragon
manages to eat all the gold just wait
for it to poop out a massive gold nugget
and then market it as an extremely rare
resource i'm just saying if people in
reality can sell dice made from the poop
of an arctic swedish moose imaginary
duck people would go insane for dragon
poop gold
[Music]
there's simply no way that the kids
could see this from that far up
first let's just say they all survived
this as nobody was wearing a proper seat
belt when the plane crashed
second where is this hose attached
they're on vault island and the other
end of the hose just sort of leads out
to
the ocean that is not how hoses
oh work that's my girl for some reason
you all want to wear the cinemasins
pitchfork m on your body
so we slapped that [ __ ] on some new
merch and threw it in the store posters
hoodies tanks socks click on the merch
below the youtube player or click the
store link at cinemasins.com
there was no baby it was full of cats
yes
yes oh my god as if somebody had a gun
to your head
said you got to tell me what's going on
with this person over here or i'm going
to kill you
now you mr connor you are staring into a
deep dark pit of trouble if you don't
let me help
wake up how did you find the piece of
resistance
we have to hurry all right hang on
tight ah
it's not a liquid